أريد أن أوضح
أنني سأقوم برفع بعض الضرائب،
العديد منكم مليارديرات هناك،
وسوف تتوقفون عن دفع نسبة 3
%،
ليست مزحة
فكرة أن الملياردير كان
لدينا 600 ملياردير أو نحو ذلك في الولايات المتحدة  في
أمريكا الآن هناك ألف
فكرة أنهم يدفعون بمعدل
أقل من معدل
ضابط الشرطة أو مدرس المدرسة أو الممرضة، وهو أمر
غريب
في التاسع من مارس، وسأشرح
بالتفصيل كل شيء وكل ضريبة
هناك ما أقترحه
ولا أحد يزيد عمره عن 400 شخص ويكسب أقل من
400000 سيدفع فلسًا واحدًا أكثر من
الضرائب ولقد دعوتهم إلى
الجمهوريين، وعليهم أن يفعلوا الشيء نفسه،
وضعوا اقتراحهم على الطاولة، لقد
صوتوا ثلاثة  مرات يستمرون في دفع
فواتير أمريكا لسداد الدين بدون
شروط مسبقة بدون أزمة
إذا سددوا الدين الأمريكي فلماذا
بحق الله يهددون بعدم
سداده الآن